Traductor: Frank Zegarra
Revisor: Emma Gon
Los humanos conocen el sorprendente
pinchazo de una aguja,
el agudo dolor al golpearse
un dedo del pie
y el punzante dolor de muelas.
Podemos identificar muchos tipos de dolor
y tener múltiples formas de tratarlo.
Pero, ¿qué pasa con otras especies?
¿Cómo los animales que nos rodean
experimentan dolor?
Es importante que lo sepamos.
Tenemos animales como mascotas,
enriquecen nuestro ambiente,
criamos muchas especies
para nuestro alimento
y experimentamos con ellos para
promover la ciencia y la salud humana.
Los animales son
importantes para nosotros,
por lo que es muy importante
que evitemos causarles dolor innecesario.
Para animales que son similares
a nosotros, como los mamíferos,
a menudo, es obvio
cuando los herimos.
Pero hay cosas que no son tan obvias,
como si los analgésicos que funcionan
en nosotros también les ayudan.
Cuanto más diferente sea
un animal de nosotros,
entender sus experiencias es más difícil.
¿Cómo te darías cuenta
si un camarón tiene dolor?
¿En una serpiente?
¿En un caracol?
En los vertebrados, incluyendo humanos,
el dolor puede ser separado
en dos procesos diferentes.
En primer lugar, los nervios
y la piel sienten algo dañino
y comunican esa información
a la médula espinal.
Allí, las neuronas motoras
activan movimientos
que nos hacen rápidamente
huir de la amenaza.
Esto es el reconocimiento físico
del daño llamado nocicepción,
y casi todos los animales,
incluso aquellos con sistemas
nerviosos muy simples,
lo experimentan.
Sin esta habilidad, los animales serían
incapaces de huir del daño
y su supervivencia estaría amenazada.
La segunda parte es
el reconocimiento consciente del daño.
En los humanos, esto ocurre cuando
las neuronas sensitivas en la piel
hacen una segunda ronda de conexiones
desde la médula espinal al cerebro.
Allí, millones de neuronas en múltiples
regiones crean las sensaciones de dolor.
Para nosotros, es una compleja experiencia
asociada con emociones como miedo,
pánico,
y estrés,
que podemos comunicar a otros.
Pero es difícil saber cómo
los animales experimentan
esta parte del proceso
porque muchos de ellos
no demuestran lo que sienten.
Sin embargo, tenemos pistas al observar
cómo se comportan los animales.
Los animales salvajes y heridos son
conocidos por cuidar sus heridas,
hacen sonidos para mostrar su dolor,
y se vuelven solitarios.
Científicos en el laboratorio descubrieron
que los animales como pollos o ratas
se autoadministran fármacos para reducir
el dolor cuando están heridos.
Los animales también huyen de situaciones
donde han sido heridos antes,
lo que sugiere conciencia de las amenazas.
Esta investigación
nos ha permitido asegurar
que los vertebrados reconocen el dolor
que es ilegal en muchos países herir
innecesariamente a estos animales.
Pero, ¿qué sucede con otros tipos
de animales como los invertebrados?
Estos animales no están
legalmente protegidos,
en parte porque su comportamiento
es difícil de comprender.
Podemos hacer
buenas conjeturas sobre algunos,
como las ostras,
gusanos,
y medusas.
Estos son ejemplos de animales
que no tienen cerebro
o tienen uno muy simple.
Una ostra retrocederá si se le chorrea
jugo de limón, por ejemplo,
debido a la nocicepción.
Pero al tener un sistema
nervioso simple,
es improbable que experimente
la parte consciente del dolor.
Otros animales invertebrados
son más complicados,
como el pulpo,
que tiene un cerebro sofisticado
e incluso es uno de los animales
invertebrados más inteligentes.
Aún así, en muchos países, la gente sigue
la práctica de comer vivo al pulpo.
Incluso hervimos vivos a
langostas, camarones y cangrejos
a pesar de que no sabemos
cómo les afecta.
Esto nos plantea un problema ético
porque les podemos estar causando
un sufrimiento innecesario.
La experimentación científica, a pesar de
ser controversial, nos da algunas pistas.
Pruebas en cangrejos ermitaños muestran
que ellos dejarán su caparazón
si reciben electricidad,
pero se quedarán
si es un buen caparazón.
Y los pulpos que pueden enrollar
un brazo herido para protegerlo
arriesgarán usarlo
para cazar a sus presas.
Esto sugiere que estos animales hacen
juicios de valor de la entrada sensorial
en vez de sólo reaccionar
reflexivamente al daño.
Se sabe que los cangrejos se soban
repetidamente el punto de sus cuerpos
donde han recibido un shock eléctrico.
Incluso las babosas de mar se encogen
cuando saben que están cerca
de recibir un estímulo nocivo.
Eso significa que tienen cierta memoria
de las sensaciones físicas.
Aún tenemos mucho
que aprender sobre el dolor animal.
A medida que nuestro conocimiento crece,
algún día podremos vivir en un mundo
donde no causemos dolor innecesario.